he's Jalen Rose from the mothership who
set to join us now NBA analyst and also
the new show get up with mike Greenberg
Michelle Beadle starting next week the
cast member and Jay wrote joins us now
let me start with that do you think that
Ben Simmons should be eligible for
Rookie of the Year Jalen I think there
should be a distinction between
first-year players performers and
rookies okay you brought up the issue
rule example the saying to happen with
our Dida sabonis he paid internationally
I think for eight or nine years and came
to the NBA he was on the thirty years
old and won Rookie of the Year that
awesome that all makes a mockery of the
award the strategy with marquel Folds
coming back now and what he can give to
the 76ers what's your take on I'm sorry
the strategy is that he's the number one
overall peaking and you mentioned so
many great performers that have been
rookies this year and so if you could
get them back into the lineup and get
some productivity from him or a team
that is going to not only make the
playoffs but in an Eastern Conference
that really isn't in a scramble other
than LeBron James because he's been the
constant in that conference the
Washington Wizards haven't gotten John
Wall back the Boston Celtics seem to be
decimated by injuries including Kyrie
Irving the Toronto Raptors are flamed
out in the playoffs the last few seasons
other than one time of making it to the
Conference Finals so if you're the
Philadelphia 76ers things can break
right for you he hopes it probably would
around it you explain to me the shooting
form with more careful - there's has to
be a story behind this Jalen Dan I'm
hearing that initially when he got
drafted and by the way it was because he
had a really good stroke yeah shot he's
got a high percentage from three he was
really good from the free-throw line and
then you go number one and if for some
strange reason allegedly a trainer of
his working with him decided due to his
shoulder injury and trying to protect it
that they could do it by changing his
shoot
for not anything to do with the actual
team in itself and so once that took
place you not only was dealing with the
shoulder injury but he was dealing with
a funky jump shot that he was unable to
now regain confidence in his shoulder
and a shooting stroke that didn't give
him you got but surely the heal properly
and more importantly make shot which is
why you saw some of those videos that
went viral where dunk shot just looked
like a double klutz
it had no chance to go in at that point
it looked pretty good last night I liked
the form I just didn't like him lowering
his release point because he had you
know he's got a good wingspan there and
he was taking he was taking away one of
his weapons by lowering it I agree and
one of the things I like about him is
that he's really wiry has long arms and
long lamps and one of the things I like
to do what young players is when you're
on your knees raise your hand to force
them to shoot the basketball high and if
you could block it from your knees then
they know they have to lift it up so I
agree with you he definitely is gonna
have to lift it up above his shoulders
to get it off accurately he's Jalen Rose
of course covering the NBA for the
mothership and starts his new show with
mike Greenberg and Michelle Beadle it's
called get up and when is that April 2nd
guys debut Monday April 2nd the same day
as the NCAA national championship from
South Seaport New York City what is this
show going to be all about I'm excited
to participate on a show with greenie
and beetle and we're not here to I guess
change the landscape of how you cover
sports the scores from the night before
don't change regardless who's delivering
them but I just hope that we're able to
provide a quality show with some trust
trustworthy personalities of segments
and some interviews that people are
going to be excited about in a way to
cover some sports and entertainment and
politics and current events in a unique
way that we're having a lot of fun and
people gravitate to is there a beef
going on with your
grandmother and sister Jean hilarious
Vicki said it because when I see you
guaranteed to be an ICU and considering
the fact that sister Jean is 98 and Mary
Bill Hicks is 100 I would think that
that term does not exist but I would
praise it it just became a coincidence
devotees were able to make it to the
final four and play against one another
sister Jean and Loyola Chicago have been
a terrific story making it this far as
the number 11 see and for those that did
not know before the video I posted my
mother whose name is Jean coincidentally
and my grandmother who just turned 100
last August are huge basketball fans in
particular for the University of
Michigan so she saw the video because
they continue to go viral and showed her
on TV
so what Michigan won she asked me cuz
she is more rebuttal I was like you
really protect like I'm really
protective of my family and like I've
never really done that with my
grandmother or my mom like try to put
them online or try to put them on
television or something like that and so
I talked to a few of my family members I
have older brothers and whatnot and so
they said ok with it and so once she
recorded it again I asked 50 more people
is do you think I should really do this
and then they were like yes it's a
beginner be fun so she got a kick out of
it I'm glad people got a chance to enjoy
it and it's just all in fun and this is
what makes the NCAA tournament great do
you still have your Michigan uniform I
actually have one of our my Michigan
uniforms coach Brian Dutcher
now the head coach at San Diego State I
ran into him recently and he actually
pulled it out of a bag said I have a
surprise for you gave me a white number
5 Michigan jerseys and I have it hanging
in the closet right now if it wasn't
Michigan where where else were you going
I took it
few visits so one was normally I was the
kind of kid I wanted to pick a school
where I saw people from Detroit have
success so I took a visit to UNLV at the
time Anderson hunt with the Final Four
MVP teaming with Larry Johnson Stacy
Altman and Greg Anthony took a visit to
Syracuse because Derrick Coleman was
there has a success and God my
Godfather's Dave being who also played
in the NBA with my biological father
Jimmy Walker and I took a visit to
Michigan State cuz C Smith was there
have a success so those were my visits
before I ultimately chose the University
of Michigan I saw your dad play nights
on good or bad your dad was a talented
talented guy but I liked that he was
good at basketball thank you for
acknowledging I'll never forget Dan I
was a lost sixth grade fan Washington
was the athletic director at st. Cecelia
st. st. Cecilia where you was a proving
ground to play basketball and I was
goofing off in a gym and he took me down
in the basement and a lot of people
won't get this analogy but he had a
projector he had stuff sewn there had
two big reels on the antes I want to
show you something he's blowing up the
deep-blue to dust in my face he's like
he put on the footage of my father plant
and he shot him doing a spin dribble
he's like you know he's one of the first
big guards that put people on his hip
and turns and he can make shot that he
was story led the NCAA in scoring he did
all these great things and you up here
picking your nose messing around I'm
never gonna call you jealous every day
he called me roles he was like until you
show me you can do something I'm never
gonna call you by your first name so
that really became my motivation at
basketball can become my life that's
great hey good luck on Monday and thanks
for joining us always great to talk to
you jaylen that's Jalen Rose ESPN NBA
analyst and get up cast member that'll
be on Monday with beetle and green
dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show ass
[Music]